we have the  very simple answer  the shortest way to the peace  is to supply more weapons to ukraine  that's why from the international  community we need three things  weapons  weapons and once again weapons weapons  number one this is just the weapons  necessary for ukraine for game changer  we need just 300 tanks  1 000 on personal carrier and 100 jet  fighter and this has completely changed  the whole character of the war  point number two  we need  the  sanction and embargo  and the arabic world can play here and  very important role by increasing the  oil production and to replace the  absence of the russian oil on the world  global market  and point number three is a complete  isolation of russia complete isolation  of putin until putin stop the aggression  withdraw their troops and launch  negotiation about their security  guarantee  look everybody understand that if we do  not stop  russian on ukrainian  soil  the war will knock at the door of their  own countries  you